钱不是省出来的
那是怎么来的
我们就当说这个话呀
有去过年的时候
就回家跟老人说钱不是省出来的
但是
现在怎么来的
对吧
这句话对不对对钱
不是省出来的
而且越省钱可能越穷
但是我们一定要搞明白为什么
以及到底该怎么这么钱
我是穷胖的
所以我
我基本上20
25岁之前脑子一直想一个东西就我所有的努力都成为的政策
就重怕了吗
我
比如说买个努力
我要在
各种对比 各种做所
两个要是
上个一百万岸
大概是这样
我还带我这事儿我估计你们现在很多人还在干呀
就是
那个时候往上priu那个政法的软件吗
为了政策网上到处做到办的
这个办的事
到处做到办的这个不对的
但当时就这样
然后还自己还觉得
对 我什么钱了
我我我我怎么样了
但是其实我后面这个慢慢慢慢这个思维开始办的那边了以后我才看着有钱我才认识到
其实越省钱越穷
为什么
当然这个
不是和就是你正在
生存线上你正在生存线上我现在说得不好不
不是用啊但是一旦过得生存线
你又我建议大家可以听听我这个罗教
族物理学里边有一个特别基础的逻辑
一个原理
被费曼称之为最包容的基础原理
说什么呢叫
最小
量原理
什么叫最好乱原理呢就是一个
真正
稍微有点复杂一点不过后面就简单了啊就是
一个真正好的系统
他
一定是使用的最小量啥意思
简单说就是
成本最低的
但这个成本最低这个最小量是只全局的不是局部的
关键就在这
你看我们什么钱
没问题这个是成本对不对但是
我们忽略另外一个事这是局部的啊
忽略另外一个事什么是全局的事
就全局真正的成本可不值钱
包含了钱
包含了事件就你还浪费了点事了
对吧
包含了轻力注意要时间和轻力不是一个事
比如说我今天
我有事件但是我经历不好
对吧我今天有点难受
心情里不舒服那其实这个时间被浪费掉了
还有一个就是机会
非哥呀全局考量除了钱之外还有时间
然后还有这个经历然后还有
这个机会就有些是刚搞的机会
这个位置我就可能稍微
拉出一点给点儿带分享一下为什么我们很多时候
会秦的原因
就是我们很多时候正前的垃圾叫做现金随
他有的时候是即使的
要和我们过去的工作方式有关比如说我们工作一天
工作一个月马上就先进去
就是机制性的这个我刚才说马上就要接钱
对他马上能看到
所以其实我们很多时候
我们正前是用加剑法算的
我怎么正前呢我这个月干了马上接期接期
我今天干活了马上接期
大不了一天干完了要要去接期
就是马上能看到结果
所以有的时候如果
这个要很久以后他能看到结果的时候一般来说我们接受不了
所以很多人是没有
我们叫做长级思维的
没有没有延迟满足这个逻辑了这个稍微放一半
这也是我们很多人的问题
讲一下吧
你可以
能听懂听懂听懂不要听我们在听后边的东西就是
真正赚钱的事
其实都是只是书记的
而只是书记的时候
只是书记的事
通常前期是看不到结果
好
那外的对钱吧
就刚才我们说什么钱的事比如说过两个要是做成了一百块钱
对一个要是上了五周一钱
是不是这个逻辑
你要知道这个事的天花板
就是一百块钱
花点还是周图上回来的结果 天花板就有它的
你不可能说我以后我以后我以后我以后
比完嫁一个华还找我钱 不可能
对了
所以这个天花板就是那个商品的结果比如这个东西就是三百块钱
好了两个小时你浪费的就是三百块钱
最多就是三百块钱
这个是先先听话吧就在这
但是注意真正赚钱是什么是长法甚至是指数
是长法甚至是指数
所以这个位置就稍微反而赛一点
就是我说一些我的情况
然后呢用我是从英国来的然后我以后掌握一些房租之后我现在可以这样做我跟他讲一下
比如说我是不会现在以前也是的现在不会就说我会的
比一个价格上个几百块钱让我去我去那个差价了为什么
这个说个大家都知道的事情吗比如说我拍头视频
基本上只要拍平均一条视频但他收一手百块钱
对了我拍头视频大概是十分钟
主点准备倒拍是基本上大概是这样子
那么假时候是两个小时两个小时我也是
我就爱五百块钱算吧是不是
那你会发现我上这个钱
我我我我干我去比价
那你会发现我不拿这个钱去拍短这边的
我还可以拍好多条呢
是是这样如果一半所以
我个人的话现在已经想成两一个一个过程一块事情的就是我给自己订阅
就是订阅时信
只要我做这个事整省钱是超过我的实行的对不起
对吧我就是我就起起说了
那能说完我没把算实行对吧我本来就没钱
注意
这就是一个轻人思维
我一会说一下一会儿一会儿一会儿一会儿算了就现在说吧
轻人思维是什么
首先第1个
就是他认为自己的实行不是钱
对吧他认为自己的实行不是钱
但是副人他他花时间他花钱每一块时间
对不对因为
时间在求认这是消耗品
我我打什么事件我打给打给游戏吧
我说个是凭吧我打个麻箱吧对吧我把这个时间消磨了
他是消耗品
但是你会发现在副人这什么呢他是他是一个生产权权
就是我把那个我要我花钱每一块时间然后因为我的时间可以去做更多的事情所以
在很多那股存里我的时间是不是钱的
这个思维你要是不偷跟你讲比如说你报价的报报你报什么价格你都是按成本价
比如说这个事做成本打给游戏我加点价
能够这么报价的
这就是成本思维
真正报价
就报报价报什么报价就是按价值
你管我我成本多少呢对吧我给你带来十二块价值我要五万
我要三万我不OK
正常啊
对不对而不是按成本对这是第1个成本思维
第二个思维就是滚亏效用
简单来说就太快
就是你脑子的一本只看着这个结果
你脑子只看着这个结果其实你的思维是没有看到别的路你看不到机会的
你看不到这个价你这个时间还可以干什么
对吧你看不到的所以其实你会发现你的认识会下载
我们说有的时候为什么我们会穷就是因为我们没有选择
就是我们没有没有没有选择所以这就是我们平穷园园
我这个的特别又带一圆
然后我们我们再拿
对吧这就是为什么我们平穷园园园
那到底该怎么赚钱
我给大家几个方法
几个方法啊你们就感受一下首先第一件事情就是你做几件事
第一件事别自已定个实行
去找到你能赚钱转得最多的那样
你看看这个事能不能重复走
就是你自有喜欢的这个事能赚钱
重复走 定个实行
对吧
这是定个实行
那有的事如果
定于这个实行
高于这个实行你可以做的标准的第二件事情
只要这个事长本
他是做的我什么才这个钱
和我的这个实行
比如说
我
这个事我省能收拾五百块钱
或者收拾五千块钱
我这比如说我实行是一千块钱
但是我实行可得不一千块钱
低于百分之五十
对不起
能外包的一千百包
因为我完全我的实行可以赶别的事
对不对 这是我们这第二点事
然后来说第三点是这个是一定要切极一定要切极
什么在实行赶吧
省在实行不算你抬游戏的
省在实行不算你说实行的省在实行不算你抬受的
省在实行赶一家一眼是低
可能去干
能给你带来更高收拾这个事
那很多人说我没有更高收拾这个事好 第二点是
去学习一个长期之的投资的事
比如说写作
比如说
这么多产品比如说怎么做
这么多
对吧 比如说怎么做演讲
比如说怎么做产品怎么做英雄
就学习这样一个长期来说非常有用的技能
第三点是
去做一个什么事呢
做一个就是你现在做了这个事之后
你未来可以就让大家那时间
你呢 我来说其实我每天有些时候会规则我的题词又好的程序
我这个要是做了以后未来每天可能会经常一个叫实行
却做这样的事情
这什么时候第三个事
第四个事 我们脑子要给我思维
什么思维
就是我们在计算的时候 不能只看一个位度
你要看多个位度
就当我们什么钱这个来说 我们上个是钱
对吧 这是一个位度
但是一场同样的时候 我们的成买包完什么
包完钱
包完实现
对吧 包完经历
包完机会
对
所以我们要真正要做的不是
局部的优化
把眼光方远一点 放得更高一点 我们要做
全局的优化